what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna watch today
the official trailer for The Last of Us
this is my best Joel cosplay equipped
together at the last minute join with me
is one of my best friends someone one of
the first people who really heavily
encouraged me to play The Last of Us and
I played this game twice since then
played the second one twice since then
Andrew Gordon how are you Andrew I'm
doing great dude that cosplay is sick I
I actually almost said hey what's up
Joel when I walked in here so I mean you
were killing it with that I appreciate
that this is good rapport we are
developing on camera together I am so
excited for this ladies and Gentlemen
please leave a like uh we are planning
of course uncovering this show right
here on this very Channel because I I am
so jazzed that there's been a lot of big
trailers this week any little extra bit
we can get of this outweighs any trailer
we've seen all right let's go
[Music]
if you don't think there's hope for the
world
oh my God
damn it looks so much like the game yeah
we haven't seen the world flickers so
you don't know
keep going for family
yeah no
your cargo
I love the music
it's almost the fact that I didn't turn
into a monster I see so much twitches
definitely your personality yeah
oh this song
oh I remember that point yeah Henry and
Sam
you got any advice on the best way west
you've come this far the northern lights
and you know what's out there
they hear based on sounds
scared who
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know who those guys are
I must be yeah Marlene
is that Ashley Johnson
I think so be careful who you put your
feet
your father
true songs yeah
David yeah it's Gotta Be
we didn't see him on the casting list we
were looking it up beforehand yeah we
did
oh
that was amazing
so good that loader holy crap that was
great oh my God [ __ ] that effects looks
insanely accurate oh my God it's scary
that's really scary yeah I mean we saw
like a little bit of everything like
look we're just gonna talk as if you
know the game
We're Not Gonna really try to explain
everything for you guys so if you guys
haven't played the game you might want
to just click off right now and that's
totally fine yeah I mean we got to see a
little bit of everything here from like
pretty much the whole game it looks like
in the snowy Parts this must be the part
where the like David and the cannibal I
call them David and the cannibals but
then of course there's like a bunch of
new imagery here that I don't know who
this like Native American who ordered
these guys yeah
they're the who they're talking to do
you have any idea who these guys are new
characters yeah it must be new
characters because they don't look
familiar to me but which I'm glad too
because I don't want this to be a
specific carbon copy yeah I want certain
images yeah yeah I want obviously the
same characters and all but I do want
them to add you know new characters and
offer some new scenes as well even
though the first game is pretty much
perfect yeah but I I don't want to feel
like an exact carbon copy obviously
there are things that I don't mind that
they're gonna do from the video game of
course but I don't mind that they add
some layers and cut like giving Ellie I
know she had a sense of humor in the
game and she just had that commanding
presence to her and I love whenever she
cusses too it's it's one of my favorite
traits of her personality she's probably
my favorite video game character I mean
and I mean look the the Crux of the the
strength of this show like in the video
game is going to be based on the the
chemistry and the relationship between
Pedro Pascal and Bella Ramsay I mean
like I said I want to see a lot of if uh
stuff from the video game for sure but
I'm very curious like these new
characters that we see in other
characters uh that get expanded upon and
I really think we were talking about
this earlier I think it's a great idea
that they're making a TV show rather
than a film because we get to see
characters fleshed out more we get to
spend more time with these characters it
would be hard to justify everything in a
two and a half hour film with you know
how new on constant How Deep The and
layered the the first video game is so
I'm really glad they made the decision
and we got Ashley Johnson right there
Ashley Johnson that's cool to get hurt
in here yeah given birth during the
apocalypse yeah I believe Troy Baker 2
is going to be in this as well he's
going to have a little bit of a cameo so
to get Ashley Johnson and Troy Baker
that's cool there's glad you spotted
Ashley Johnson right there in the heat
at the moment yeah that's great it looks
like he's gonna be playing an important
character actually especially because so
much of the game you know when you're
doing a survivalistic type of Apocalypse
game you want to capture the little
glimmers of hope for the future of
humanity and it looks like her
characters the fact that she's giving
birth is going to be in some way a
service to that you know we gotta hear
more this time of you know Pedro Pascal
doing the dialogue as Joel We got to
hear more Bella Ramsay doing the
dialogue is Ellie Pedro Pascal is
absolutely killing it like they're both
making it their own it still feels like
in the likeness and hearkening to what
we loved from them from the video games
but I think like what they're doing in
terms of the presence and the aura that
they bring for those roles I think
they're both nailing it I know there's
been a little bit bit of a back and
forth debate over Bella Ramsey as Ellie
yeah because like you know despite the
fact that Pedro Pascal is a Latino no
one seems to even notice that when it
comes to it which I think is really cool
that we're just like yeah Victor Pascal
he just the way he carries himself the
body language the presence the demeanor
the delivery seems like Joel but it's
still making it his own where Bella
Ramsay I feel like she I I want to see
more of her but what I'm with the little
glimpses for getting of her I think
she's doing a really good job and I'm
not distracted by it I mean and also too
like putting her on a pedestal from the
character Valley you just said she's
your favorite character it's it's hard
when you're again when you're going off
a character that's so beloved and like
if you're not nailing the first look
like Optics are a very big thing before
we actually see any footage so I can
understand why people were very not sure
if like just from the look if Bella Rams
is going to do a good job again just
from the little glimpses we're seeing
I'm loving the Rapport that we're seeing
between her and Pedro Pascal genuinely
too I love that off screen they have
such a like for each other you know it's
such an again the relationship to me is
so endearing it really compares to me to
Ellen Ripley and new to the Terminator
and John Connor so I just I see so many
similarities and nuances there so this
is really a tough and really deep
relationship that really has to be
nailed down so again I can understand
people's not being negative but just
maybe having just some like hey not sure
about his this she doesn't nail the look
of this like Ashley Johnson just nailed
that voice down so I can understand but
so far just from everything we're seeing
chemistry-wise off screen and on screen
I'm really liking what we're seeing and
obviously again to me that's going to be
the biggest strength of the show is
their relationship I mean obviously I
love all the other characters from the
video game but that's where the strength
of the show is going to rely on
something to me feels like because you
know I think what they're doing with
this show is I think they're probably
going to divide this the storyline of
the first season uh I I feel like
they're probably going to cut it off at
after David is killed and that will be
the end of season one yeah where they
set off to go to the Firefly Camp
something tells me that that's where
they're going to end in Spanish
yeah I mean it would be because that is
such a crucial turning point for both
those characters in that moment you know
especially for
um uh Ellie you know when she like gets
her revenge and murders this guy I think
that would be it and then you could do
an expander because this looks like an
extended version of the game in a lot of
ways I mean so much with Bill we didn't
get to see Frank and we just alluded to
Frank in the first game this time looks
like we're gonna see part of their
friendship it seemed like in the game
that they might have been like lovers or
something like yeah that's that's what I
thought too but that's why I love that
they're going with the TV show stuff we
didn't see like the Frank that you just
mentioned in Bill storyline like we only
got a little bit of Bill in the game and
I love W Earl Brown who of course was
the camera guy Courtney Cox's camera guy
in Scream one I'm glad that uh we're
getting gonna get more of Bill and uh
his play by Nick Offerman in this uh
show and the Frank storyline because I
was actually I know that was not a very
big thing in the first video game but it
was still as impactful yeah it was
impactful I'm like I want to see I want
to see more about it so yeah and I'm
glad too that we saw in the the IMDb
cast list we saw that Riley is going to
be yeah there's a little glimpse of her
here yeah so yeah so I'm glad I thought
that was really cool that they included
that in the video game you could play a
prequel to the events that led up to the
start of the first game so I'm really
excited to see that because that that
prequel is so freaking awesome it's not
very long or anything but it's freaking
awesome yeah and I'm really glad that we
got Merle Dan uh Dandridge back as uh
Marlene yeah because obviously she
voiced her in the game so it's really
cool they got Ashley Johnson they got
Merle Dandridge they got Jeffrey Pierce
who voiced Tommy Miller Joel's brother
Tommy he's going to be in this show as
well he's playing a character named
Perry I believe is what it said it's
really cool and then they got the
composer Gustavo from the first two uh
games oh that music the western music so
I'm just excited guys what did you think
about this trailer leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a
like click that Bell uh keep a lookout
when we cover this show follow Andrew on
Twitter igor711 on Instagram we'll catch
you all soon thanks Andrew for being
here thank you all for being
[Music]